here's Justin Trudeau saying Canada is a
place of free expression
[Music]
as you can also see Canada is a place of
free expression where individuals and
communities are free to express
themselves openly and strongly and we
thank them for sharing their
perspectives
oh you soulless lizard man that is the
same Justin Trudeau who as you know was
closing down Trucker's bank accounts
calling half the country racist and
transphobic because they were trying to
get their stores and schools open and
churches and other places of worship etc
etc but this guy as far as I can tell
has no human soul that he can go up
there and constantly say the exact
opposite of what his actions would prove
that he's for free speech and it's so
wonderful that we have free speech here
when he crashes down on the people that
try to exercise their free speech so it
should not surprise you that Justin
Trudeau does want to regulate big Tech
because you know people are saying mean
things how far are you willing to go
with regulating social media companies
and what do you say to those who think
that it's an attempt to stifle free
speech I think we've seen that that the
impact that social media particularly
around hate speech around intolerance
around incitement to violence is a real
problem in our communities we need to
always walk that careful balance between
respecting rights to free expression and
free speech and keeping our community
safe and unfortunately what happens in
the virtual world sometimes spills over
into the real world and I think it's
really important that social media
companies understand their
responsibility to uh to shape and to
ensure that our communities stay safe
for everyone prime minister is just such
a vapid nothing it's not really a social
media's company's responsibility to do
anything other than make product make a
product that event hopefully makes the
the founders some cash and employs a
bunch of people and puts out a good
valuable thing in your pocket on this
thing right that's what a tech company
is supposed to do now we'd like people
to be a little bit nicer online I
suppose as I always say you can block or
mute or just not look at your phone
um but you know he conflates three
things there first off he talks about
hate speech now first from an American
perspective and of course he's the prime
minister of Canada but from an American
perspective there is no such thing as
hate speech the Supreme Court has
litigated on this and if you are going
to have free speech then you can't have
something called hate speech right
because one person's free speech is
another person's hate speech so we do
not from an American perspective have
hate speech now of course Canada does
not have the the protections around
speech that we have in the United States
it's one of the things really that and I
would say the Second Amendment the first
and second amendment our ability to
speak freely in our ability to own
weapons are the things that are keeping
us from going off that Cliff that Canada
seems to be going off of this
authoritarian uh Cliff so he talks about
hate speech then he also talks about
intolerance people are going to be
intolerant it's just how it is it's just
how it is Justin Trudeau I find you
rather intolerant of half of Canada uh
and certainly anyone that believes in
the things that I believe in so if I had
the power should I ban you do you see
that this is a two-way street and you
could be uh you could be screwing
yourself once you go down that road